going back to the michael jackson days
at some point michael jackson when you
were on tour with him this is all from
the documentary it's and i and i
recommend it to everybody you're talking
about how michael says come over and
visit with me nothing sexual obviously
it was just like hey come come over and
you guys watched amos and andy movies
which is weird in any way you want
you're sitting there with michael
jackson biggest pop star in the world uh
watching amos and andy
and then the chimpanzee is there in the
room with you and in order to discipline
the chimpanzee he starts poking him with
a pen in the chest i got so offended by
that that he was poking this poor little
chimpanzee in the chest with a pen you
must have been appalled
well this poor little chimpanzee that
could have picked him up and thrown him
out the window you know right and ripped
his face off and ripped his face off you
know right i'm just trying to like
i'm just trying to like stay in my body
because
michael's laughing at amos nanny and
throwing popcorn and poking bubbles in
the chest
and i'm just this
you know
girl who just moved to l.a seven months
ago who used to be a school teacher
and
it's so weird i will tell you one thing
howard making this documentary was
such a weird experience because
you basically just hand over a pile
of archives and
and stuff i've never even seen and
sitting and being interviewed for hours
on end and
recalling all this stuff and recalling
the the harshness of some of these
situations
was so
draining and also it was in a weird way
liberating to finally talk about it i
mean a lot of this stuff i've never ever
talked about